(upbeat music)
- Hi, my name is Emmy Eaton,
and my favorite thing to
do in my hometown, Idaho,
is I like potatoes
and then eat them.
There are more than million
potatoes made each day.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Except I don't like it
when they're all dirty.
We walked into the room
where there were a bunch of potatoes
and there was like a conveyor belt
that was holding up the potatoes.
It shot water everywhere in there.
And then we got to the
big stack of potatoes.
They have to wait one
year in the big room.
They have to keep it nice and cool,
so there's sand everywhere and stuff,
'cause they don't want it
to go rotten and moldy,
'cause that's gross.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, Drew.
My name is Simone,
and I am in my hometown
of Baltimore, Maryland.
I love Baltimore
because it has so much
history and so much beauty,
but the thing I love most
here is the food scene.
I'm a food blogger here in the area,
so I post all the best eats
and drinks in Baltimore.
So I wanna show you around
to some of Baltimore's
most fun, and exciting, and
delicious foodie destinations.
(upbeat music)
- First stop is Belvedere Square Market.
Say hello to my friends
at Neopol Savory Smokery.
In general, they sell all
kinds of smoked goods,
but Neopol sells my favorite
sandwich in Baltimore,
their salmon BLT
and their famous New
Zealand smoked mussels.
These are a must-try here in Baltimore.
Last stop at Belvedere Square
Market is Tasha Flowers.
I come to Tasha to get my bouquets
for my living room, kitchen,
bedroom for the week.
- So we're gonna grab
this Asiatic lily here
because look at that.
- Yes.
- It is beautiful,
perfectly open.
- Uh-huh.
- That's just a little peek
of Belvedere Square Market.
Now moving onto our second stop,
welcome to chat hour at
Good Neighbor coffee shop.
We'll have some
very creative appetizers,
great conversation.
Well, Drew, that's just a small look at
my beautiful city of Baltimore.
I hope you loved it as much as I do
and I hope to see you here soon.
Bye!
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Drew.
It's Sam.
I'm a Halloween lifestyle blogger
known online as @halloweenhappy.
I'm in my apartment here
in Salem, Massachusetts,
and I am so thrilled to show you around.
I love Salem so much because
there's a lot of history,
there's always something to do and see,
and it has a Halloween
vibe all year round,
which, clearly, you can
tell I'm obsessed with.
So grab your broom and hang on tight,
and let me show you around
my hometown of Salem, Massachusetts.
We are at Modern Millie, which
is one of my favorite shops.
I love coming here because they're so nice
and they always make me feel
so comfortable in my skin
when I'm trying new things with my style.
I see that they have a
few Halloween outfits,
so let's go check it out.
This is Tiffany.
- Hello.
- Hi, thank you so much
for inviting us in.
Tell us a little bit about the shop.
- We are an exclusive women-owned
shop in downtown Salem.
We sell reproduction
vintage-inspired clothing
from size extra small, right on up to 6X.
And we're happy to help
style anybody when coming in.
- Thank you so much for showing
us around Modern Millie.
Right, guys, onto the next spot.
Let's go!
All right, Drew.
So I'm a crafter at heart,
which leads me to our
last stop here in Salem,
and that is The Witchery.
So let's go inside and
talk with the owner, Gret.
So what do you offer here?
- So The Witchery is a creative space
and we offer book binding workshops,
and we offer broom making workshops.
And behind here, you can see
some of the brooms that we make.
We let people choose their own materials
to create a custom broom.
- So if you do visit Salem,
definitely check out The Witchery.
That way you can make a
craft, take it home with you,
and it's like you're taking
a little piece of Salem along with you.
Well, Drew, that's just a snapshot of
my hometown of Salem, Massachusetts.
I hope you love it as much as I do.
I can't wait for you to
visit and I'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)